[Music]
was there a real decision made to bring
in unexpected talent that would start to
really define these films even more
individually I think as we were as we
were entering phase two the idea was to
to continue doing what we had done in
phase one which was not just telling new
stories with those same characters but
making the same kind of choices with
regards to cast with regards to
filmmakers that we had made the first
time and that did mean filmmakers who
hadn't necessarily done quote-unquote
giant movies before but who had a unique
point of view in a unique angle on on
the world Shane Black certainly fit that
bill for Iron Man 3 when we got to a
part three I had always vowed if I was
ever lucky enough to work on a film that
had gotten to a part three that I would
use that as an opportunity to do
something unique it could be very easy
by part three to fall into a trap of
being too familiar or too similar or
just more of the same and I look back on
my favorite film series and the ones I
love the most were the ones that did
unique things in part three and those
were also the ones that would often
continue to four five six seven eight
for example of course return the jedis
my one of my favorite part three's ever
even the search for Spock you know led a
new deep in the mythology of of Trek
which led directly to the voyage home we
could do a whole interview about the
Star Trek if you want even and this is
one I've the Friday 13th movies Jason
Voorhees didn't get the hockey mask
until Friday 13th part three you think
of one thing when you think of Friday
13th Jason Voorhees in the hockey mask
weird example as compared to the MCU but
an example of deepening and further Nate
furthering a film series in in unique
ways and often in ways that that people
don't even realize that that Hakeem I
stood in fear until part three it's so
inherent with with the material so with
Iron Man 3 we really wanted to take Tony
to new places we had a great advantage
that the Avengers have been released
between Iron Man 2 and Iron Man 3 so
suddenly Tony had a whole other level of
anxiety that he had to deal with and the
other thing we did was look to
television we hadn't necessarily done
that in the past and I knew there were
great filmmakers working in
in television and that was how we found
these amazing brothers that directed
great episodes of television with
Arrested Development and community and
brought them in for the Winter Soldier
the Russo brothers were just a huge
discovery did you know at the time that
they were going to be you were going to
sort of hand them a huge responsibility
of shepherding this this series forward
Joan Anthony Russo our great filmmakers
from the very first meeting we had on
Winter Soldier where we said their names
keep popping up on these cool television
shows that we love let's meet with them
they completely understood what we
wanted to do with the Winter Soldier
they they inherently understood the 70s
political thriller nature of what we
wanted to do with that film they're also
tireless they're also incredibly
talented and that led directly into
civil war and it was midway through
civil war where we said you want to do
two Avengers movies at the same time for
us what they say they said yes without a
doubt and we're very glad that they did
they also have the stamina required it's
very difficult to make one of these
movies much less two of them and I think
they're training a lot of their
television work and more importantly
what they had always envisioned
themselves becoming as filmmakers all
work was required and and helped drive
them through to where we are today James
Gunn was obviously perhaps the most
different vision to bring to your
universe where did the galaxy the
guardians of the galaxy come from why
did you decide to go down that path but
in phase 2 phase 2 for us was continuing
the stories we started in phase 1 and
introducing new stories we didn't want
to be a studio that only made Iron Man
films or later only made cap or Thor or
even just Avengers films so it was
important to us and we always knew in
Phase two we wanted to do take another
swing and that was Gardens the galaxy I
always wanted to do a space movie I
always wanted to a franchise set in
outer space and what we had great access
to was the Marvel Comics which at the
time they had relaunched the guardians
characters and included Rocket Raccoon
included Groot and it seemed like the
most unlikely group of misfits ever put
on screen and seemed like something that
would be incredibly fun
and I loved telling people that we were
going to do this movie Gardens a galaxy
with the raccoon and tree and people
going I don't know you're talking it
like you guys have gone crazy James Gunn
did have that reaction initially
but as he as he will tell you he was
driving home and he thought more about
the characters and he started to realize
he could he start to fall in love with
the notion of this raccoon he had an
unbelievable take on it and he wrote a
new outline the cover of which had a
picture of the very first Sony Walkman
and I looked at I went this is gonna
work
because we knew we want a Peter quill to
have a connection to earth in a way that
most intergalactic outer space heroes
didn't don't have and when I saw that
Walkman I said he's gonna do it through
music which is genius and that's what he
did almost definitional in the same way
as the The Avengers Assemble shot is a
police lineup such an ingenious way to
introduce that brave a-holes the mugshot
lineup in guardians one was James idea
it was something that he'd put in the
script a way of getting to know the
characters seeing who they were learning
a little bit about their past in this
humorous setting it was so good in the
early drafts that he wrote that we knew
we could use it in marketing so we shot
it very early on in the schedule I don't
remember exactly one but my memory was
in the first few weeks of production we
filmed that and it was that very first
clip we showed a comic-con of the
guardians galaxy anywhere and in those
quick little vignettes you got to know
almost all of them and and where they
were coming from what their attitudes
were what their names were but it set
the tone right off the bat and that's
one of the great things about James he's
an unbelievable
filmmaker great writer great director he
knows these characters and he breathes
this life into them and can distill them
down into moments like the lineup that
audiences never read a guardians comic
in their lives didn't know it existed
can immediately grab onto them we also
get snow Thanos a little more in this
Brolin seems so perfectly cost why was
he the perfect person to play this
villain of all villains who are about to
meet well fan OHS goes back with us to
the very end of phase 1 to those last
shots of the first Avengers film just
wrote him in to the script he just turns
around you see his little smirk and that
really was the beginning of us beginning
to seed his grand story arc culminating
in the Finity war and as we were working
on guardians we wanted to to touch on
fan us again and action
see him for the first time and we wanted
to cast a great actor and we knew we
were heading towards infinity war so may
as well try to get the actor that you're
gonna use and Josh Brolin was the idea
that popped into our head the only name
ever associated with a nose for us and
it was our great fortune that required
just one phone call and he sort of
immediately understood what we wanted to
do and entrusted us that's a big that's
important thing for us you meet with
these incredibly talented actors you
explain your grand vision for where this
character go over the course of many
years that conversation was with Josh
was probably four or five years ago now
but that one day it'll he'll be the star
of his own movie and it'd be a great
thing I imagine people on Hollywood talk
like that all the time and 90% of it is
doesn't come to fruition and it's always
important to me that what we what we
pitch these actors we deliver more
importantly Josh Brolin delivers an
unbelievable performance so he he sat in
his chair and his big fan of throne for
that one scene in guardians with the
promise that he would have a showcase
role in Infinity Ward down the line what
josh has done of course we can't talk
about too much nobody's seen it but what
he's done with that character in that
performance is is overwhelming is
astounding he's he's a he's an amazing
talent so Ultron obviously was the
another climax for her phase and it
seemed such a compelling time together
of a lot of the conflicts that have been
happening particularly around around
stark and trying to contain technology
why was he the perfect villain for that
second Avengers film the notion of
Ultron is the bad guy in of in the in
the second Avengers film goes back to
conversations we had with jaws during
production of the first Avengers film I
remember being in the lab set on the
Helicarrier and started talking about
vision and start talking about Ultron I
start talking about Tony being the one
to create Ultron and that it being a
spin-off the here vision being spin-off
of Jarvis which had which had taken off
in the first in the in the Iron Man
series from that point it was just a
given that Ultron was going to be the
bad guy and then in the in the second
Avengers film which was great because it
also tapped into this angst that Tony
Stark continues to carry with him
through infinity war this man who had
this wonderful read em
generic and doesn't sell weapons anymore
and doesn't want to contribute to to the
ills of society and suddenly being
exposed to aliens and other worlds and
other threats from beyond and Avengers
and how that affects a man who's a
futurist and who constantly is looking
for ways to solve problems and his way
in in an age of Ultron when awry which
only causes him more angst it's followed
by ant-man which is a which is a
fabulous chaser in a sense because it is
a little lighter and smaller than Ultron
which is so epic obviously the story
leading up to ant-man with Edgar coming
off the project
he said that Marvel didn't want to make
an Edgar Wright movie is that a fair
assessment of what happened with him
leaving the project no I think the idea
with ant-man was always to do a heist
film right and talk about different
genres leading up to it the the
adventure film the sci-fi fantasy film
the space opera we wanted to do a heist
film with that man and what Peyton was
able to do when he came on board
tilda understood that concede in that
promise and the amazing cast that had
come together on that film Michael
Douglas which was unbelievable to work
with and Paul Rudd who had been a comedy
star but suddenly stepping into the the
super heroics not in a completely
different way than Robert had done and
becoming these iconic characters the
placement of that movie also on the
heels of Avengers do a giant movie with
age of Ultron then do something mmm
figuratively and literally much smaller
with that man to continue to to surprise
people
does that not answer your question at
all
you